Andthere
[Music]
and here the download in Portugal is still in
turmoil here it is UOL HOST and the time they
are taking it there was another one is
neighborhood wait
working in the Americas the levels of
Violence at study selection in the
countries like Brazil Are completely Out
of Control on
most drug dealers live in the favelas the
police try to control this
crime they end up entering the
favelas and taking the lives of
innocent people who are not related to the
criminality of drug trafficking
unfortunately today and they are a cycle ends up
being a vicious cycle
Andthen
I  was Power police closes nor jump
America ar de 100 da Have been born in
the chips Are you in the seventies
knew minecraft rap don't see the
pictures of every One including Souza a
se
Andthere
[Music]
Ethere
Andthere
[Music]
Hi and Neto are those Quality isn't it
that I leave the National Police
constant no stability Possible Level 1